so this is a good place to
bring up a difficult topic you mentioned
uh
they might they would be paying
attention to us to see if we come up
with any crazy technology
there's folks who have reported ufo
sightings there's actually i've recently
found out there's uh
websites that track this the the data of
these reportings
and there's millions of them that's in
the past
uh several decades so seven decades and
so on
that they've been recorded and
the ufologist community as
they refer to themselves you know one of
the ideas
that i find compelling from an alien
perspective
that they kind of started showing up
ever since we figured out how to build
nuclear weapons
that we should what a coincidence yeah
uh
so i mean you know if i was an alien i
would start showing up then as well
just why not just observe us from afar
no i know right
i would figure out but that's why i'm
always uh
keeping a distance and staying blurry
right but
very pixelated very pixelated you know
that there is a
something in the human condition that a
cognition that
wants to see wants to believe beautiful
things
and uh some are terrifying some are
exciting
uh goats bigfoot is a big fascination
for folks
yeah and ufo sightings i think falls
into that there's
people that look at lights in the night
sky and
i mean there's it's kind of a downer
to think in a skeptical sense to think
that
that's just the light yeah you want to
feel like there's something magical
there sure
i mean i felt that first when my dad my
dad was a physicist
when he first told me about ball
lightning yeah when i was like a little
kid very weird
very like yeah weird physical phenomena
and he said
his intuition was telling me this is a
little kid
uh like i really like math his intuition
was whoever figures out ball lightning
will get a nobel prize
like he i think that was a side comment
he gave me and i i decided there when i
was like five years old or whatever
yeah i'm gonna win a nobel prize for
figuring out ballet
that was like one of the first sort of
sparks of the scientific mindset
those mysteries they capture your
imagination i think when i speak to
people that report ufos
that's that fire that's what i see that
excitement you know i understand that
but what what do we do with that because
there's
hundreds of thousands if not millions
and then the scientific community
you're like the perfect person yeah you
have an awesome einstein
shirt i mean what
what do we do with those reports it's uh
most of the scientific community kind of
rolls their eyes and dismisses it
is it possible that a tiny percent
of those folks saw something that's
worth deeply investigating
sure we should investigate it it's just
one of these things where
you know they've not brought us a hunk
of kryptonite or something like that
right they haven't
brought us actual tangible physical
evidence with which experiments can be
done
in laboratories right it's it's
anecdotal evidence
the photographs are in some cases
in most cases i would say quite
ambiguous i don't know what to think
about
so david fravor is the first person he's
a navy pilot commander
yeah and there's a bunch of them but
he's sort of one of the most legit
pilots in people i've ever met
right the fact that he saw something
weird he doesn't know what the heck it
is
yeah we saw something weird i mean i
don't know what to do with that and
one on the psychological side so i'm
pretty confident
he saw what he says he saw which
he's not provide he's saying is
something weird right
one of the interesting psychological
things that worries me
is that everybody in the navy
everybody in the u.s government
everybody in the scientific community
just kind of like pretended that nothing
happened
that kind of instinct that's what makes
me believe if aliens show up we would
all like
just ignore their presence that's what
bothered me that
you don't you don't
investigate it more carefully and use
this opportunity to inspire the world
like so in terms of kryptonite
i think the conspiracy theory folks
say that whenever there is some good
hard evidence
that scientists would be excited about
the uh there's this kind of conspiracy
that i don't like because it's
ultimately negative
that the u.s government will somehow
hide the good evidence
yeah uh to uh to protect it of course
there's some legitimacy to it because
you want to protect
military uh secrets all that kind of
stuff but
yeah i i don't know i don't know what to
do with this beautiful mess
because um i think millions of people
are inspired by ufos
right and it feels like an opportunity
to inspire people about science
so i would say you know as carl sagan
used to say extraordinary claims require
extraordinary evidence right i've quoted
him a number of times
uh we would we would welcome
such evidence uh on the other hand
you know a lot of the things that are
seen or perhaps even hidden
from us you could imagine for
military purposes surveillance purposes
the us government doesn't want
us to know or maybe some of these pilots
saw
soviet or israeli or whatever uh
satellites right
a lot of the or some of the crashes that
have occurred
were later found to be you know weather
balloons or whatever
you know when there are more
conventional explanations
science tends to stay away
from the um from the sensational ones
right and so it may be
that someone else's calling in life is
to
investigate these phenomena and i
welcome that as a scientist
i i don't categorically actually deny
the possibility
that ships of some sort could have
visited us because
as i said earlier at slow speeds there's
no problem
in reaching other stars in fact our
voyager and pioneer spacecraft
in a few million years are going to be
in the vicinity
of different stars we can even calculate
which ones they're going to be in the
vicinity of right
so there's nothing that breaks any laws
of physics if you do it slowly
but that's different you know just
having voyager or pioneer fly by some
star that's different from having active
aliens
altering the trajectory of their vehicle
in real time spying on us and then
either
zipping back to their home planet or
sending signals that
tell them about us because they are
likely many years
many light years away yeah and they're
not going to have broken that
barrier as well okay right so so
i just you know go ahead study them
great i you know for some young kid who
wants to do it
it might be their calling and that's how
they might find meaning in their lives
is to be the
scientist who really explores these
things
i chose not to because at a very young
age i found
the evidence to the degree that i
investigated it to be really quite
unconvincing
and i had other things that i wanted to
do
but i don't categorically deny the
possibility
and i think it should be investigated
yep i mean
this is uh this is one of those
phenomena that um
99.9 of people are almost definitely
there's
conventional explanations and then
there's like mysterious things that
probably have explanations that are a
little bit more complicated
yeah it's but there's not enough to work
with i tend to believe that
if aliens showed up there will be plenty
of evidence
uh for scientists to study yeah like and
it
exactly uh as you said
a voyager type of spacecraft i could see
sort of um
some kind of kind of a dumb thing almost
like a sensor to
like probing like statistically speaking
flying by maybe
lands maybe there's some kind of robot
type of thingies that just like move
around
and so on yeah like in ways that we
don't understand but
but i feel like well
i feel like there'll be plenty of hard
hard to dismiss evidence and i also
especially this year believe that the us
government
is not sufficiently competent given the
huge amount of evidence that will be
revealed from this kind of thing
to conceal all of it right at least in
modern times you can say maybe
decades ago but in modern times but you
know i
uh the the people i speak to and the
reason i bring it up is because
so many people write to me they're
inspired by it by the way i wanted to
comment on something you
said earlier um yeah i had said that i'm
sort of a pessimist
in that i think there are very few other
intelligent mechanically able
creatures out there but then i said yes
in a sense i'm an optimist as you
pointed out because it means that we
made it through
the great filter right i i meant
originally that i'm a pessimist
in that i'm pessimistic about the
possibility that there are many many
of us out there mathematically speaking
yeah in the drake equation
exactly right right but it may mean a
good thing
for our ultimate survival right so i'm
glad you caught me on that yeah i i
definitely agree with you
it is ultimately an optimistic statement
but anyway i think you know ufo
research is interesting and i guess one
of the reasons i've not been terribly
convinced is that i think there are some
scientists who
are investigating this and they've not
found
any clear evidence now i must admit i
have not
looked through the literature to
convince myself that there are many
scientists doing systematic studies
of these various reports so i can't say
for sure
that there's a critical mass of them
well it's just that
you you never get these reports from
hardcore scientists that's other thing
and astronomers you know what do we do
we spend our time studying the heavens
and you'd think we'd be the ones that
are most likely
aside from pilots perhaps at seeing
weird things in the sky
and we just never do of the unexplained
ufo type nature
yeah i definitely i try to keep an open
mind but for people who listen um
it's actually really difficult for
scientists like i get
probably like this year probably gotten
over
probably maybe maybe over a thousand
emails on
on the topic of agi
it's very difficult to uh you know
people write to me is like
how can you ignore this in a gi side
like this model this is obviously the
model that's going to achieve general
intelligence
how can you ignore it i'm giving you the
answer here's my document and they're
always
just these large write-ups the
problem is it's very difficult to
we through a bunch of bs right
it's it's very possible that you
had actually saw the ufo but you have to
acknowledge
that you know by ufo me and an extra
terrestrial life right
you have to acknowledge the hundreds of
thousands of people
who are a little bit if not a lot full
of bs
right and from a scientist perspective
it's just
it's really hard work and it's um when
there's amazing stuff out there it's
like why invest yeah
bigfoot when evolution in
all of its richness is right beautiful
who cares about a monkey that walks on
two feet or eight
like there's a zillion decoys at
observatories
yeah true fact we get lots and lots of
phone calls
when venus the evening star but just
really a bright planet
happens to be close to the crescent moon
because it's such a striking pair
this happens once in a while so we get
these phone calls oh there's our ufo
next to the moon and no it's venus and
so
they're just and i'm not saying the the
best you for reports
are of that nature no there's some much
more convincing cases and i've seen some
of the footage and blah blah
but it's just there's so many decoys
right so much
so much noise that you have to filter
out and there's only so many scientists
so it's hard there's almost
only so much time as well and you have
to choose what problems you work on
you know
you